[Applause]
protesters Park hubby bogiver Avenue and
the Heart of Tunis
they want president a Saeed out of power
the street has long been staged for
political change 12 years ago protests
grew here spread across the country and
within weeks toppled longtime president
zini al-abidim benalin
[Applause]
now opposition groups that have long
been Rivals have unified and they
include the national salvation front
coalition and the free Constitution
party
on the anniversary of the Revolution
they are more united than ever before
and a lot of progress has been made in
this particular Point
um the way out is quite simple uh is it
is actually a dialogue a national
dialogue between stakeholders in this
country and national uh um
representative of the different
political forces
in what many saws and attempt to placate
the protesters the president attended a
rally on Friday one man shouted to him
they're hungry
the country is an economic crisis
inflation is soaring jobs are scarce and
a 1.9 billion dollar bailout from the
international monetary fund is being
discussed but with many concern the
country is becoming more authoritarian
the United States May block it
last month's parliamentary election saw
11 of Voters cast ballots it was meant
to reshape the legislature dissolved by
the president after he seized executive
powers in July 2021
but now Kai said is under pressure from
growing opposition groups and anger on
the streets
Al jazeeran